the Joe Rogan experience apparently
they've traced it to a very specific
type of animal I thought that this thing
always transfers I think Moshe told me
this that that birds need a pig the pig
is the perfect conduit of transferring
like the Burt Bird disease won't come
from like straight to a person it needs
to go to a pig and the pig get infected
what about avian flu I don't know avian
flu came from birds this may be that's
and I think bats gave it to pangolins do
you know what a [ __ ] penguin is
mm-hmm Whitney was telling me this that
a Pangolin is like the most the most
what is the word you would use where
someone is uh transferring animals I'm
[ __ ] slow today man my brain slow
today yeah that uh the most exploited
most exploited animal and the worth you
know what a penguin is uh uh some weird
[ __ ] Hangul in Pangolin I think it is
never heard of that yeah um
there it is that [ __ ] thing look it
up there put a screen look that that
thing that's called a penguin penguin
yeah that is the most exploited animal
in the world and they eat them in China
and so this [ __ ] thing is where shots
China has laws to stop Pangolin
trafficking yeah I think it's freaky men
yeah they're they have laws that they're
they're imposing now to stop the sale of
wild animals you can't sell wild animals
in the United States but you can sell
well you can sell wild fish but you
can't sell wild animals the United
States that's one of the weird things
about fish what about those like exotic
people in like that documentary you know
like why aren't those wild animals I
mean for food oh oh oh okay okay I mean
for food okay um
you can't like even in this country it's
like most trafficked animal yeah
adorable penguin is the most trafficked
animal in the world how is that possible
ask Whitney Cummings she's the one who
told me and it seems to be true yeah
it's in the New York Post as well there
it is the rainforest of the Congo camera
in Central African Republic lives an
elusive mammal that looks like a cross
between an anteater and armadillo and a
pinecone and thanks to poachers the
Pangolin is the most trafficked animal
on earth in April of 2019 Singapore
seized a world-record 25.6
tons of Pangolin scales worth seventy
six point five million from an estimated
38,000 of the creatures in December the
scales from some 50,000 African penguins
were seized by Chinese authorities what
do they do for it I don't know it's
because of this scale this unique
feature that makes them a target said
Tessa almond a volunteer for the Sangha
Pangolin project a Preservation Society
the Pangolin buries burro to create
holes so the scales are associated with
circulation it's used as an ingredient
in traditional Asian medicines they used
to help mothers for lactation and for
blood pressure but none of this has been
clinically proven so it's like Tiger
teeth and yeah yeah and tusks yeah
there's so much of that [ __ ] I was
talking to a Chinese guy about that yeah
and I was saying well why wouldn't you
do they know that rhino horn doesn't
work and that they could get viagra
I'll give it's make your dick hard
viagra definitely works yeah oh it's not
even that he goes a lot of it as a
status thing it's like so if you are a
really wealthy Chinese businessman and
you're into this kind of stuff like you
want to show that you skirt the laws
right animal track shark fin soup right
like isn't that wearily that tastes good
but I'm saying that's isn't that
something where there's like some type
of probe it's restriction against it and
then they're like yeah but I'm oh yeah
I'm the man so yeah
yeah I think I don't know what kind of
restrictions they have about that in
China but across the world
rhinos it's there but they want that tea
that they make at a rhino horn because
it just makes my I come we'll discuss
business over Rhino team oh yeah I mean
yeah I get why that happens but I don't
want any well China is so weird right
because it's a weird combination of
capitalism and communism yeah and not
just
but a military communist dictatorship
it's interesting you know speaking of
like the virus the way the way to China
lockdown Wu Han yeah when they decided
to mmm it's a there's no [ __ ] around
yeah no [ __ ] around 11 million people
in that city went through the streets
spraying some distant they sent 40
thousand workers to Wu Han to be like
handle this
lock it down clean it up yeah just boom
in one city and they what's it like now
there it's there well here's the thing
you can never trust with the state
governor you know the state media says
but they were saying that all their new
cases are inbound
so it's travelers coming in how
convenient it's all these [ __ ]
Italians
yeah coming over here for shark's fin
soup and rhino tea [ __ ] pasta virus
[ __ ] yeah
it's the rigatoni virus now it is you
guys did it well they're saying that the
America could be the next epicenter yeah
well New York is has more than 5% of the
world's cases right now
does it really yeah it's growing too
well New York has 25,000 cases as of
this morning that's five percent the
world's cases that's what that's what
the news was last night they say that
for every one person that tests positive
ten of them have not even been tested
that have it yeah there's there's for
sure way more cases yeah because it's
impossible to get a test a test yeah
yeah like try to try getting a test
right now in LA LA had they started a
website yesterday with all the
information how to get it tests and
they're like first of all meet this
criteria are you over 65 I mean that
really yeah part of it yeah Jesus do you
have these symptoms
you can't even order one online if you
can get a test going right now you could
be a great business it would be Jeff
Bezos and it would be a great way to
like you know figure out who needs to
really be staying home
[Applause]